first of all are you guys doing we're
yeah it's a surreal situation I would
say so we're tired and excited and hyped
and pumped up so yeah it's it's all the
emotions it's a dream bro it's a dream
yeah I want to start by saying congrats
on the movie sincerely and as I said to
you off camera and I'll say it on the
best compliment I can give you is that
this absolutely feels like a bad boys
movie it's not like some cheap version
of bad boys this is more bad boys maybe
maybe that hopefully that sounds right
or yeah that's that's the best
compliment you can give exactly because
this was that the the ambition of the
challenge we are bad boys fans we fans
of the two of the movies and and we just
wanted that at the end of the day the
audience would think we really saw a bad
boys movie was like you know it was what
you wanted to see and what what you got
so thank you so I have to ask you
obviously you've made some movies but
never in Hollywood and what is it like
what was it like coming in and sitting
down with maybe Bruckheimer or with Sony
and sort of pitching them on what you
wanted to do or did they come to you and
say you know how did that how did this
all come about for you guys well
actually the project was already there
so it was already you know in 2015 they
were planning on making the movie so
there was already a script a concept
everything and and the movie that you
saw is is basically for big part the
script that we got so so these ideas the
big themes in it they were already there
you know the the fact that they were
older the fact that you had an ammo team
and all that the sort of you know
breakup almost moment between between
Mike and Marcus all of these elements
were in it and also the fact that was so
emotional and that's what attracted us
to to that project yes so we from the
star we we made this movie called black
it got selected in Toronto Film Festival
and that's when the agents and managers
from Hollywood came to us I said yeah
you want to work in Hollywood and and so
Jerry's our movie
and he absolutely wanted to work with us
so the first day we were in Hollywood
and having a meeting with him he asked
us what kind of movies you want to make
and then we said wanna make bad boys
that was 2015 but by then you you had
you had joe carnahan was on the on the
project and then you know years later he
came back to us and it was meant to be
you say yeah that's crazy that you said
that what is it like though for you to
listen you obviously grew up watching
Jerry Bruckheimer movies what is it like
going to sit down with him for a meeting
like that even a general meeting just to
talk I mean how much were you like get
the F out of here yeah stressing a lot
for us from the moment that our our
Asian the managers which was already
crazy for us to have American people
lucky on the phone you know we only hear
American in movies it was already
surreal and they said Jerry
Bruckheimer's gonna see your movie and
we were like Jerry Bruckheimer Jerry's
eyeballs is gonna look at our stuff that
we shots it was just mind-blowing we
could not believe it so when he saw it
we were just emailing everybody movies
and and and then there was the day that
he wanted to meet us and we just
couldn't believe because I was the most
famous producers in producing the world
and we went there and we were so nervous
that we were all the time talking donkey
no pause because Jerry doesn't say a lot
no he just looks yeah sure no I know
yeah just look strong look very stylish
just said great you guys have humour
yeah be a drama so so we had to convince
them that we very funny we can't be
funny jumping into actually filming bad
boys what this was obviously again first
time having this large of a budget in
this kind of studio system what maybe
surprised you about working in the
Hollywood studio system that maybe you
weren't expecting well we you know
although we know that it was going to be
difficult because in Belgium movies are
subsidized by the government so it's
like in your creative enterprise and as
a director you do just do whatever you
want
in a small budget so in Hollywood is
different because you have like 90
million you get big stars and and and
the stakes are higher so you know it's
it's you know you don't do just whatever
you want but the thing that there were
surprises is the similarities between
between the difficulties we have in in a
Belgium project where there's never
money for anything and never time and
you have the same thing no money no time
on a bigger level because they don't
like you know you want to have two
helicopters that no there's no money for
that
come on to Michael Bay movie we will
he'll it comes an explosion explosion
there's money for that you gotta have
smaller and and there's no time like
guys we only have a day like what you
know so this really surprises we compare
it to like our first movie that only
cost like $150,000 to make sure so yeah
you have the same problems man the same
problems the machine is just [ __ ]
gigantic it's so funny though I hear
that from other people a lot of people
who are watching the movies at home you
they don't even like they don't even
realize it you know that every no matter
how much money you have and no matter
how large the schedule is it's still not
enough if you're trying to make this
huge movie yeah exactly and and and also
for us when you know when we were like
in Belgium you look at the movies at the
Halloween movies and you think come on
man you got yeah and a million to a
million and you could have pull it off
that's unbelievable and so you're there
in the suck you know all right so it's
it's not as easy as we thought you know
now you got yourself and and you know
the audience at the end of the day
doesn't care but it's it's yeah it's
unbelievable you know that sometimes we
had to find creative solutions and still
think it it's only a hundred million
dollar movie right yeah another thing
that that was also real challenge was
like we had to shoot big party in
Atlanta and make it look like Miami in
the summertime yeah and Atlanta in the
winter doesn't look like Miami in the
summer
that was also surprised because we
really know where that laughs that
looked like because we're from Belgium
we get a job through Miami in Atlanta
all right all right correct from the
moment that airplane lands we look does
look like Miami we got a problem so so
that was a big challenge yeah this was I
don't know if you've ever done test
screenings in Belgium but what is what
was that process like for you guys
because did you do test screenings on
this and what did you learn from showing
it to audiences in Belgium you don't
really do test screening only with
friends or family
but here you do really a real test
screen we had like 8 or 9 of those
because it's it's an action-comedy and
that's the thing you know comedy you
don't know after a while the jokes are
still funny or not so you gotta check it
then you gotta test it and that's what's
what's so amazing is that you know you
have your audience you have microphones
everywhere you get cameras you know that
that shoot them so you see exactly which
joke works and which doesn't so by doing
that all the time we you know we cut
jokes out we make jokes a little better
yeah we're in the editing room every
we're looking at the audience
every time when reaction when when do
they laugh when they don't don't laugh
what they want in the story because this
is this is a movie for the people we
didn't want it to make our movie we
wanted to yeah for the audience
sometimes Jerry would come up with a
search and joking with Jerry everybody
laughs I guess it's in the movie now
Jerry's been doing this for a few years
yes he knows he know he always knows
yeah how I asked this all the time of
all filmmakers how long was your first
cut compared to the finished film well
okay so I was a week earlier than him
first get that there was 2 hours and 26
minutes yeah so and we were like how we
gonna get it down to two hours because
we wanted to have a movie that's way
shorter you know
and then another cut that we shot to the
audience first was 2 hours and 6 minutes
2 hours and 6 minutes yeah yeah yeah
and then we thought we cannot get
anything out of the movie it's yeah we
were cutting as much as possible what
but eventually yeah it's now under two
hours and we're really proud of that but
no it's not possible but it's always
possible yeah what was the last thing
that you cut before locking picture well
actually a lot of no actually I wanted
to say that the last scene of the movie
we didn't know if you wanted to have
that scene in the movie or not so it got
in it got out he got in he got out the
last the last you know really you get
the credits in it you have something
without spoiling you know we were not
sure really the last thing we yeah but I
think that one before last was basically
the action we had so much action in the
whole movie that you know we try to find
that balance because after a while it
just you know becomes you know pretty
boring even though there's a lot of
explosion or all the people getting shot
and all that so so eventually we had to
reduce as much as possible just so that
you can stay with the character so that
is like the thing that we really had to
cut yeah sure do you guys envision doing
like a quote-unquote extended cut on the
blu-ray or is it just gonna be deleted
scenes well no I was gonna stay the same
yeah maybe we're gonna put some more of
the slow motion cool shot cuz we wanted
to go all the way bake em and if it no
guys you know you gotta you know well
there's actually want to bring that up
there's an awesome shot of there's a lot
of moving camera and a lot of stuff that
I thought was really well done but there
was one shot that I remember I want to
say was on a rooftop I saw the movie
last week the like it's the camera sort
of zooms in on a rooftop and then it
sort of pulls out and it's on like a
helicopter or like a drone yeah
you know and I'm like oh that's a
[ __ ] cool shot yeah so how did you do
that well he was our DP a Belgian DP who
these are students short movies images
as his 31 young guy looks 15 year old
and and he he always wanted to do cool
drone shots that are not just drone
shots metz things that are real close on
to the character you became sort of a
trademark of our other movies and it was
very difficult technically because it
didn't work on that roof and and I had I
came up with a sort of idea like you
know what if we just start closely we
put him in profile and then you pull
back and there was a rig and then and it
all started together like get the rig
off and it flies you know and that was
really difficult to pull it off but it
eventually it worked and also with with
some CG help and all that that's what
made this is just such an iconic moment
because we really wanted to you know
yeah we shot it also a tad what was it 6
a.m. 6 a.m. in the morning you know
everybody was dead tired and this shot
was so difficult but yeah we made it
work thank you for the compliment yeah
yeah that's a great shot thank you but I
know there was a few of those kind of
shots in the movie so I am curious you
mentioned that you had other cool
slow-mo shots do you think looking up
I'm basically pitching on you to try to
do an extended cut so you can put in all
the [ __ ] yeah you know or just show it
to me so I can see it you know there
were a couple you know usually usually
when the shot was like to where there
was too much violence or blood yeah
that's where the producers in the studio
scene I know it's r-rated but don't go
overboard with the with the final
version is bloodier yeah so our version
cool shots combined with some core stuff
it might be an extended version or in
there in deleted scenes yeah these are
things I want to say yeah I'm a fan of
this kind of stuff and I'm sure there's
other people who are watching this
interview who feel exactly the same so
how long did you guys actually have to
shoot this thing so we shot it in today
is actually exactly a year ago that we
had our first film it was first shooting
day on January 14th and we we ended it I
think three months April April 22nd was
the last day so it was like would say
about 6065 shooting days
yeah that's actually not that much for
an action involving action like this no
yeah it was it was really you know
that's what I mean there was not enough
time he squeezed the schedule and were
like really in 65 days so it was it was
pretty tough but we managed we had a
great team great crew and and Waylon
Martin is super motivated so so we
managed to do twice as much we do so so
that's how we yes no do you I apologize
for not knowing did you have a second
unit or did one of you splinter off
sometimes for second unit well he was
both so we had a second units because
we're - we would splinter off and I
would be with the second units and the
second unit director and he would be on
the first unit and sometimes I would go
from second gear to the first and back
and forth and we got really tired he's
always like super fresh how he does it a
lot of coffee yeah probably
a lot of coffee no but that's the thing
I Bell bade that people don't realize is
like I think he has the record for
setups in a day I think he did like a
hundred yeah - 25 in a day which is like
ungodly yeah you know I don't understand
how he does that
yeah and still and still sharp - yeah I
still have that focus I mean we were -
so I'm we're lucky yeah if I'm alone I
would die yeah also we're younger than
he is and he still does that now and and
we were like dead tired at 20 and then
Jerry comes in always super fresh you
know Michael it doesn't all over his own
you know and he still works and he
barely sleeps when you're saying you
guys are obviously been friends for a
long time what was the last big
disagreement you had well there's a lot
of those in our private life but we're
like brothers it's you know everything
like sometimes I'm saying yeah I want to
eat there and he's like no we're gonna
eat there so most of the fights are
about food yeah yeah brother stuff but
really on on the on the set so when we
make the movie we're always together
I think the going the the latest big
disagreement is is how to say something
like we have an idea and how to to you
know communicate that idea
and and he will say okay let's let's
think about it let's you know do it in a
calm way and you know you know and chill
and I'll just go full all the way
craziness which sometimes can be a
boomerang in your face after that I
should have listened to you and
sometimes it works that way sometimes
yes you got a smooth operate and I'll be
bad cop all the time I understand I want
to jump into a few spoiler questions
other things that you know so the first
is how did you get Michael Bay to do a
cameo in this movie yeah so it was he
was not bad that easy actually because
he was doing six hundred grants so he
was very very busy but for us it was
just you know it was like super
important it wasn't homage he was
important you know it was like you're
having his blessing on the movie so we
did everything to get him and eventually
had that one day you know what is that
one moment that we could get him and for
a very short period because he was doing
post-production and any we wanted to do
a Michael Bay shot with Michael Bay you
know there was like that but also he
turns you know and any other actor would
have needed like ten takes to do it
right but he did it why thank you right
away he's the one taker yeah he said we
were also super nervous because you know
Michael bacon we heard that he can
scream Oh cruel words on his movies so
they were all like you know like a bit
hardcore stressed yeah but yeah
eventually came to this it's like a
super nice guy
and but he said one thing to us he said
don't [ __ ] up my baby Yeah right so how
much did you know the whole time that
that was the scene can you describe what
the scene was and was it always that
that Michael was gonna do or did you
have ideas to put him somewhere else in
the movie yeah there were a couple of
places where we tried to put him but I
think you know one of the producers came
up with a new one y-you know the MCU
of the wedding it could be Michael Bay
and you know it's it's cool to have him
and the two actors you know Willem
Martin they're present as well and also
he says Uncle Mike which for us Michael
Bay's oh my dear Uncle Mike so that was
like perfect
that was like yeah the perfect place to
to have him there and the perfect you
know timing in the movie to have that
that greats you know little wink what is
it like walking over to Michael or did
you walk over to Michael and actually
give him direction
well Michael was really awesome nervous
he was nervous he was like did I did I
do it good yeah you [ __ ] Michael Bay
the camera movement but he was you know
after for this particular shot he just
took over he explained to the steady
camera how to do the shot anything
directed he shot it were like
everybody's yeah Michael is very like
I've seen Michael work and Michael is
Michael he is the boss yeah do you know
what I mean and if you're working with a
lot of his crew so what is it like I
mean you're I'm saying like just I mean
III thank you for sharing that story
like that's just awesome no it's cool I
mean for us he was just like watching
him actually direct his own shot in a
Michael Bay she's like oh man below you
permit us any file awesomeness you know
we were just like in our of that moment
that this is like my personal favorite
shot of the movie yeah I hope this shot
will be get studied in film school did
you show him the movie have you seen it
yet no yes it was also doing his movie 6
anniversary it was like didn't have the
time yet but some of his friends saw the
movie yeah and they called him and they
say I gotta admit it's good you know
it's funny because I would imagine he
wants us to be good yeah because this is
his baby
yeah but at the same time I'm sure
there's an element that he's like don't
make it too good
you know yes I mean I understand that
completely because this this movie you
know it's it's no match to his Sinha
might so much to the Michael Bay movies
of the 90s movies I grew up in so so I
think it's gonna be interesting to see
that because it's it's not a Michael Bay
movie it's it's a Amb homage to a
Michael Bay movie completely um so I
want to get into some specifics of the
actual script I was very surprised that
will get shot in the film how it was
that always in the script early on yes
yeah yes actually yeah it was so so
these elements that are like you know
the most shocking or surprising elements
these were always in the scripts when we
got it at least and this is what also
surprised because he was it was
interesting to read a bad boy script
that is surprising that has twists and
it is this emotional you didn't expect
because you have a certain expectation
when you get that script for the first
time in your mailbox and and the fact
that he gets shots so quickly
you hooked yeah in there and you don't
expect it because it's also it means a
lot for the character of Mike Lowrey
that is like this legend
and all of a sudden there's this
weakness you know and that's what
attracted us to the story and what about
the whole son thing was that also was
also all of that stuff was in there yeah
the beginning yeah
yes that's the reason why we were like
okay this movie can be this is a real
movie to be made it's yeah it tells the
story we didn't expect from a bad boys
movies you get this other side of the
two characters becoming older and having
all this this cool twist in the story
yes so that twist for us reading it was
like oh yeah cool that's that's another
level you know I'm curious obviously
every movie goes through some sort of
changes when you're making it through
whatever like something on set hat
whatever what was there any big change
that happened from when you first got
the script to what people are seeing on
screen in terms of the story in terms of
something you weren't expecting you know
well the thing is that it you always
have that you the balance between how
much humor how much drama and how much
action that's that change
somehow yeah say you know because
otherwise you know there was a lot of
humor in the script but it was it was
really dark sometimes really heavy and
we come from you know our movies are
pretty dark and heavy so the first
version of the of the of the movie which
was closer to the script was super dark
you don't really like like the European
drama I really takes place in the in the
neighborhoods of Brussels so we had to
like step take a step back and and put
elements of fun back in it which were
already present but but we just go you
know I mean it's violence darkness drama
we go overboard sometimes so it was good
to do have a step back so that is like
the biggest difficult I'm like everyday
like will and Martin they that the
hardest work in the business like every
day after the shooting we went to every
scene every line every joke everything
so it was constantly changing but the
whole structure of the movie was always
the same God you have an after the
credits scene it's a little bit not it's
after the main credits but not after the
whole credits talk a little bit about
how that specifically came about and
let's talk with that yeah well dad
that's like when he said that was last
thing to be put in the movie you know
that was because he went back and forth
a hundred times nobody knew what to do
you know where they the studio or Martin
what do we put it in or not and we did
from those like eight or ten test
screenings with we screen it with and
without all the time and and eventually
by screening it without the audience
felt like they needed some kind of
closure with you know with one of the
characters and that's what we we put it
back in you know yeah really close to
the title not like in a Marvel movie
after the credits because we it's not a
superhero movie so so that's why we
decided to put it in just to have that
closure and you know who knows maybe you
know he's successful there might be
another one well what I want to know is
well first of all when did you actually
film that was it during the actual shoot
no no that was that was a we shot that
in the reshoot so it was actually
after our first screening of the
director's cut that we yeah we saw we
have to fill in these story lines so
that was a decision that we made and
actually during because we only had 65
shooting days there were some scenes
that we didn't have time to shoot and we
knew that we were going to shoot that in
additional photography so we had already
planned the days that we were going to
shoot new stuff and that's what that
idea came about like a-alice
you know as triads because nobody was
sure whether or not we had to put that
in a movie
sure was there an idea that you almost
did for the after the credits or was it
always that scene in that jail cell well
there was an idea to do like something
with humor you know we had some of the
the jokes and we did that actually it's
a joke with Martin the airplane we put
that like a little bit later so it was
always an idea to that some of the jokes
that we had to cut or make sure he could
put something humoristic at the end but
not necessarily a scene it did that that
scene was it was the only new thing that
we came up during the editing I think
I'm I'm sure you're gonna agree with
this but I think almost every movie can
benefit from additional photography
after the first edit and after the first
test screening because you learn what
you need yeah it's really hard to get it
all on the on the shoot yeah do you know
that the the rich should change the
movie so that's uh it's when you start
the movie you start to shoot you you
never know 100% what the movie is gonna
be yeah so after the shoot you see all
the yeah all the all the things you you
all the story beats you need and it was
not a lot but it changed that little
stuff and for us I mean all the
directors that are really geniuses they
can do it right away without any reshoot
it's pitch perfect from the start we're
not on that level of genius yes or maybe
we'll never be but our movies we did in
Belgium we always had reshoots and
Richards there's something you don't do
in Belgium there's no money for it but
we always do it like with small crew and
we steal some shots and it's because in
the Edit it's as if the movie has its
own soul and tells you what it wants to
be so if it was to be a love story yeah
and you wanted to do a lot of action and
stuff no you're gonna have to shoot some
more love scenes but but also with with
movies specifically and you've touched
on this this is a very unusual tone
sedessa have action it has to have
comedy has to have drama and it's about
figuring out the balance of those three
things yeah it's not one thing which I
think is maybe a little easier to shoot
on its first try yeah you know exactly
exactly and that's also you know
sometimes we add like an action sequence
and it never works and they just realize
yeah but there's only action there's
nothing of character in that scene so
you shoot some extra characters scenes
in the reshoots and then the whole
action sequence start to work and that's
what when the editing want to move you
out the test audience tells you
basically completely I'm just about out
of time with you but I have to ask I
don't know if you are still doing this
so I apologize but are you still doing
Beverly Hills Cop
well everybody asks this question
because we really want to do that stem
that would be an honor it's I think
Jerry asked us to be yeah sure so I'm
like okay okay I'm gonna tell you a
secret if Jerry actually won look if he
had a good time working with you it's a
good chance oh yeah you know what I mean
because I heard he has a little bit of
power
I heard that too yeah I think you're
right brother so basically at this
moment it's like there's nothing
definitive or are you
well now it's because you know these are
first Hollywood movie we gotta wait you
know until it comes out until you know
what your reaction is and I think that
Jerry is waiting just for for that you
know yeah that that God willing it
becomes a success and then he has
momentum and then he's Jim to Ryder
weeks and we met to Eddie Murphy twice
and he seems we were we were doing the
the reshoots at Tyler Perry studio and
and we were shooting bad boys and and
Eddie was there shooting coming to
America so so we said we gotta make this
happen we gotta make this moment happen
with well Martin and Wesley snap shows
there too and and anymore oh yes I saw
it's gonna be like a great social media
moment by the way it was
anyone who up yeah no that's great
listen I really mean it
Congrats on this movie you guys did a
great job with it and I really hope that
you're able to do Beverly Hills Cop or
whatever other opportunity comes thank
you very much thanks